how important is mortality finiteness
the the fact that this thing ends to the
creative process so killing in war
really emphasizes that but in general
the fact that this thing ends gee it
does it does and I was serious no
do you think about your own mortality do
you meditate on your own mortality when
you think about the work in other great
question Alexa actually I'm 75 and I
just was having I had breakfast in New
York a few months ago with a friend of
mine who spiked my exact same age and I
said to him I said Nick do you ever
think about mortality and he said every
minute of every day and I was
kind of relieved to hear that because I
do I do too
but I actually I always have I think and
I think you know the fact of mortality
is kind of gives meaning to life you
know I think that's why we want to
create that's why we want to make a mark
of some kind or and the other aspect of
it is what's on the other side of that
mortality I'm a believer in previous
lives so I I sort of and I the question
I've never been able to answer among
many many others just like why are we
even here right why are we in the flesh
you know I sort of I like to believe
that God or some force is we're on some
kind of journey but I'm not sure why why
we were put in this world where the
ground rules are if you think about
animal life that you cannot live from
one day to the next without killing and
eating some other form of life and what
a demented thing yeah you know why
couldn't we just have a solar panel on
our head
and you know be friends with everybody
so I sort of I don't get what that was
all about but that's sort of the big
issue I have you read the Ernest
Becker's denial of death for example is
that Ernest Becker is a philosopher that
said that the death that the fear of
death is really the primary driver of
everything we do so Freud had what the
right I would agree with that so it's
you you've always thought about your
even your own mortality
yes definitely and can you elaborate on
the the reincarnation aspect what you
were talking about like that we kind of
what what's your sense that we had
previous lies what in what have you
thought concretely or is it a lot of it
kind of us no I've thought can
concretely about really I mean it's very
clear when you see children young kids
or even dogs and cats that they come
into the world with personalities you
know and three kids in a family are
going to become completely different and
completely their own person and and and
that person that they are doesn't change
over life and I you know there's one of
the things that I did in my book the
artists journey is that there were
certain things where I tracked or just
listed in order like all of Bruce
Springsteen's albums are all a Philip
Roth's books you know kind of a body of
work throughout over you know a period
of 30 40 50 years you know and you can
see that there's a theme running through
all of those things that it's completely
unique to that person nobody else could
have written Philip Roth's books or
Bruce Springsteen songs and you can even
see sort of a destiny there so I ask
myself well where did that come from
what it's it seems to be a continuation
of something that was that happened
before and that will lead to something
else because it's not starting for
scratch it seems like there's a calling
a destiny in there already
this gets back to the Meuse and all that
kind of thing so yeah it's almost like
the there's this let's call it a god
it's passing it's almost like sampling
parts of a previous human that has lived
and putting that those into the new one
sampling this is probably a pretty good
work that taking some of the good boy
you can't take all the good parts
because the bad parts is what makes the
person right let's say taking all
together okay this is humans only does
it pass around from animals in your view
is that I don't know that's above my pay
grade I don't know
you